la france lance ce mardi 29 septembre
ces enchères pour l'attribution des
fréquences 5 g quatre opérateurs orange
bouygues free sfr dispose déjà chacun
d'un bloc de 50 méga hertz acquis pour
350 millions d'euros mais l'état met en
jeu une bande supplémentaire espérant
remporter plus de 2 milliards d'euros
dans l'opération ce qui va ouvrir la
voie au déploiement de la 5g dans
l'hexagone grâce à la pose d'antennes et
ensuite à la commercialisation de
forfait 5 g d'ici à la fin de l'année ah
mais j'oubliais est justement tout le
monde n'est pas d'accord on vous a pas
demandé votre avis pour la pose des
antennes vous ne connaissez ni les
tenants ni les aboutissants de cette
technologie
c'est sûrement parce que vous vous
éclairer à la lampe à huile comme l'a
fait remarquer emmanuel macron au sujet
des écologistes opposés à la 5g
je ne crois pas au modèle amish allez
circulez avec vos carriole ya rien à
voir
pour ses partisans la 5g sera très utile
permettant un débit plusieurs dizaines
de fois plus rapide que l'actuelle 4g et
la france est déjà très en retard
derrière la corée l'allemagne les états
unis ou encore la suisse la 5g serait
crucial pour les entreprises qui
pourront traiter davantage de données en
temps réel par exemple pour les
livraisons
la chirurgie à distance le cloud
computing les traitements des data à tel
point que gérard collomb a adressé un
vibrant plaidoyer pour que la ville dont
il fut longtemps maire lyon ne soit pas
noyée dans les ténèbres de
l'obscurantisme
ce dont je m'inquiète c'est du signal
que vous donner le signal que lyon ce
n'est plus l'huile d'innovation qui
porte le futur cedrico le secrétaire
d'état au numérique ne vois pas d'autre
solution pour éviter de saturer le
réseau 4g d'ici à quelques années
d'ici deux ans les réseaux 4g des
grandes villes seront saturées la
réalité c'est que nous avons trois choix
laissé les réseaux saturés installer des
antennes 4g installer des antennes 5 g
qui consomme 20 fois moins d'énergie que
les antennes 4g pourtant la fronde anti
5g à former ses bataillons une
soixantaine d'élus
mr députés responsables de partis de
gauche ont exigé un moratoire à son
sujet jean luc mélenchon yannick jadot
ou encore eric piolle le maire de
grenoble pour ne citer qu eux s'opposent
à son déploiement
ils demandent les résultats d'une étude
en cours de l'agencé nationale de
sécurité sanitaire de l'alimentation de
l'environnement et du travail lan cesse
sur l'impact des antennes sur notre
santé autre interrogation le bénéfice
pour l'utilisateur il n'aura pas tout de
suite axa la 5g faute de couverture et
faute de smartphones adaptés
il pourra possiblement payer son forfait
5 g plus cher que le précédent
alors de quoi pour essayer de profiter
des progrès de la réalité augmentée des
jeux en réseau des objets connectés dans
la maison le réfrigérateur qui parle le
radiateur qui envoient des mails de la
discussion des voitures autonomes
je vous vends du rêve voici le futur
anti amish celui des enfants des pays du
sud qui extraient les matières rares
nécessaires à la construction d'un
nouveau smartphone qui captera la 5g ce
nouveau monde fait débat on écoute les
journalistes nicolas bérard auteur du
livre 5g mon amour paru il ya quelques
mois il est censé être sa compagne de
tout un modèle de société qui veut dire
qu'on a on serait entouré de millions
d'objets connectés qui va falloir là
encore produire ce qui va nécessiter de
l'énergie mais aussi un fort
extractiviste et là encore on sait que
si on veut préserver la planète
il va falloir consommer moins de
matières premières que ce qu'on fait
actuellement la 5g va au contraire
accélérer ce mouvement là tandis que les
opérateurs et la start up née schott
affaire certains maires s'opposent
également à la 5g des citoyens lancent
des pétitions des ong pose des recours
contre son déploiement
bref alors que le débat public sur cette
nouvelle technologie semble commencer on
ne sait toujours pas qui va rendre
l'antenne cessa de mettre la carriole
avant les boeufs